uma tigresa prayer buscar alimento
todo aquele esforço durante a caçada ela
da luz
morre aquele filhotinho tigrinho ele
nasce no meio de um rebanho de ovelhas e
passa a ser criado como uma ovelhinha
comendo balima e se lamentando até às
vezes quando não lhe trazem uma passagem
mais verde mais fresquinha de um dia
surge da floresta um tigre
olha aquele tigrinho no meio de um
rebanho de ovelhas não se conforma parte
para cima dele
luxa ele com perto de um lago faz com
que ele veja sua imagem refletida
naquele lago diz 21 tigre pode desbravar
essa floresta dizer muito mais longe
e tu tens que aprender ruggia tigrinho
muito assustado sem saber direito onde
tudo que ele poderia levá-lo tenta
soltar um rugido que mais sai como miado
mas o tigre reduto ele não desiste e
depois de algumas tentativas o tigrinho
solta de dentro de si um imenso surgido
que pode ser ouvido muito longe em toda
a floresta quando olhamos neste espelho
nós enxergamos quem somos e quando nós
temos a coragem de mergulhar
profundamente na nossa essência é que a
gente descobre aquilo que a gente pode
ser essa descoberta essa linda
descoberta começou a acontecer em santa
catarina
santa catarina é um estado único
multicultural lindo como o brasil
os trotes tem tudo do campo ou marta
serra o litoral toral belíssimo todas as
temperaturas né
a gente tem frio abaixo de zero graus
também tem calor acima de 40 e só quem
mora aqui sabe um pouco o que é isso
o jovem santa catarina é uma delícia
noite efervescente a cultura
diversificada algumas das melhores casas
noturnas do mundo estão em santa
catarina
é um lugar lindo para viver a melhor
idade
ele é acima da média a que tem menos
pessoas que fumam mais pessoas que
praticam exercícios dado muito
importante ea colonização e se colono
que chegou no estado é o desbravador o
empreendedor
ele chegou com muita garra com muita
coragem havia até uma expressão
naquela época eles chamavam gente moore
gerada eu penso num livro achei muito
interessante de compartilhar esse com
era escolano empreendedor de conduta
ética ele bada forte chegava no estado
já com o sonho de fazer santa catarina
acontecer a votação da catarina no mapa
né fazer aqui sua terra onde ele
descobriu o seu sonho
as empresas que se estabeleceram aqui
logo tiveram destaque algumas delas
lideraram cenário nacional nos seus
segmentos especialmente nas décadas de
1970 e 1980 e início dos anos 90 essas
empresas elas atingiram o auge da sua
capacidade produtiva e deixar um legado
para o estado de reconhecimento em
produção a quantidade de produção
qualidade entrega serviço e até
comunicação marketing muito de vanguarda
para a época mas em algum momento quando
as portas do mundo se abrem para viver
novas experiências
toda essa floresta se transforma e não
foi diferente com santa catarina
encontrar um jeito de fazer as coisas
foi o mote que levou um grupo de
empresários líderes e tigres daquela
floresta que já rugiam eles até região
entre si para começar um novo um novo
movimento esse movimento começou como um
projeto como uma idéia uma ideia que
buscava capacitação dar um novo olhar
pro que se produzir no estado já que não
dava mais pra viver das glórias do
passado
todas aquelas competências aquele legado
tudo aquilo era muito importante tinha
feito a gente chegar até aqui mas ao
chegar aqui no presente é impossível
projetar o futuro sem pensar em inovação
sem pensar em design sempre sair
criatividade mas principalmente sem
colocar o consumidor o protagonismo
está no centro de tudo e fazer com que
dê lhe viesse a capacidade de a gente
mesmo se reinventar para entregar algo
que fosse além do produto tivesse muito
relacionado à valor experiência
propósito a construção de marca o
primeiro importante passo foi dado
o projeto começou como um tripé onde
esses líderes empresários chamaram as
instituições de ensino de todo o estado
de santa catarina com seus professores
alunos coordenadores de curso e até
outras entidades afins do setor para
pensar em conjunto desse tripé saíram as
primeiras idéias com a necessidade de se
trabalhar o que no futuro poderia vir a
ser até um apagão de talentos para santa
catarina né
essa análise muitas constatações foram
feitas justamente de que novas
competências precisavam vir sem serem as
floradas trazidas né
para compartilhar esses passos nesse
momento tigres de outras florestas
líderes inspiradores de vários lugares
do brasil e do mundo vieram pra cá pra
compartilhar como eles próprios haviam
transformado sua própria floresta sempre
começando do seu quintal mas como eles
tinham conseguido se fazer ouvir um
rugido muito mais alto e mais forte
nessa floresta global que se buscava do
estado era a possibilidade de com
autenticidade identidade diferenciação
requente reconhecendo até o potencial do
próprio estado sem precisar buscar muito
fora referenciais para a criação como
era sempre o costume daqui e vamos ver o
que tá acontecendo lá fora e trazer pra
que esse processo precisava nascer de
dentro dessas cabeças que pensavam
essas conexões quebraram inúmeros
paradigmas
nesse momento do processo algumas
empresas centenárias no estado que não
se visitavam cujos líderes não trocavam
não se conheciam passaram a compartilhar
também aquele estereótipo de que o aluno
em sala de aula o estudante não tem
muito para contribuir porque aquela
teoria fica em sala de aula foi quebrada
porque muito do conhecimento gerado no
meio acadêmico
a ser testado onde a regra do jogo
julgada e no mercado onde a coisa tem
que acontecer é possível aprender uns
com os outros e se isso já não bastasse
foi possível trocar muito generosamente
esses empresários nem abriram mão das
suas agendas tão é já a já tão cheia já
tão comprometidas para compartilhar
desde o modelo de negócio expertise que
tinha dado certo nas suas histórias o
que tinha dado errado sem muito
preconceito essas empresas centenárias
também interagindo com empresas que
gringos aquela floresta que tinha
nascido ontem começaram agora a sua
caminhada mas vai entendendo que eles
tinham grande desafio de rugir muito
mais forte para se fazer ouvir na
floresta global
essas trocas foram sempre muito
importantes ea quebra de paradigmas
essas conexões aconteceram entre as
empresas mas abrindo as portas para que
esses estudantes e os seus times
criativos fossem sendo formados para
transformar o estado nem a produção do
estado
a gente conseguiu dar um novo olhar
aproximar essas conexões possibilitaram
um que a gente entender se as
necessidades que estavam aqui no mundo
globalizado nessa floresta global com
tanto tigre fugindo mas com os
potenciais que nós também temos dentro
de casa aquela mesma gente apaixonada do
começo ele mesmo coloca aquela gente
mulherada tava que ainda estava dentro
do estado fazendo acontecer a gente
precisava valorizar isso
ao longo desses quase dez anos que esse
movimento tem se ele começou como um
projeto evoluiu para um programa
porque quando nós começamos a entender o
movimento a gente viu que o mais difícil
era desaprender o status como estava
estabelecido a gente achava que sabia
tudo afinal empresas com mais de 100
anos
e aí a grande realidade veio netinha
muito questionamento engraçado é que se
desaprender trouxe pra gente a noção de
que cada vez que a gente estabelece uma
conexão movimento ficava mais forte ea
gente entendeu que não era uma década em
talvez o suficiente para transformar
tudo aquilo que era necessário até
porque cada vez que a gente encontrava
uma resposta
que mudar era a pergunta e aí o ciclo
começava tudo de novo
há dez anos eu posso compartilhar que
fazia o único olhar pra dentro fazer
esse mergulho dentro de si não tem sido
uma tarefa das mais fáceis
a cada dia a cada novo protagonista que
entra em cena a cada empresário que
adere ao movimento a cada estudante que
além daquilo tudo que faz
como seus trabalhos acadêmicos ele diz
sim para esse chamado e vem compartilhar
com a gente o desafio é no mínimo
desbravar o desconhecido mas a gente tem
feito isso com muita atitude com muita
coragem com brilho no olho quem está
dentro do movimento está com muito amor
e sabe que não é por uma década que nós
vamos perder uma história linda de cento
e tantos anos que esses tantos tigres
dessa floresta aqui ainda vão fazer
santa catarina hoje mais alto
a criatividade o brilho no olhar de
talvez 20 mil estudantes impactadas
direta ou indiretamente pelas
capacitações
a gente vê a cada momento desses talvez
350 foram mais diretamente transformados
quando passaram pelas empresas ajudaram
a gente pensar fora da caixa e levaram
também muito desse conhecimento do que
acontece lá no dia-a-dia dos grandes
desafios da organização
então imaginem esse movimento sendo
feito a muitas mãos com grande desafio
de desaprender de largar o velho de ter
coragem de abrir o coração e buscar um
novo mas principalmente de quebra
paradigmas para compartilhar porque todo
mundo tem algo para deixar nesse
movimento
esse mergulho na própria essência tem
sido possível a moda e design de santa
catarina tiveram coragem de se olhar no
espelho e fazer esse mergulho
será que nós estamos aqui não podemos
fazer as nossas próprias novas conexões
será que a gente também não pode rugir
mais alto
será que a gente não pode fugir
mais forte obrigado